oh this is going to be really cool
I'm not sure what to expect
but I'm getting a challenge from Brigham
for Doc spellcha so somehow he found a
way to combine variants
and
I assume it's just gonna be
duck chess with spells
I'm not sure if we can freeze a duck
but let's find out
okay
so
I've never done this before
play E4
I can place the duck but can I use a
spell too let's place a duck
let's hold off on using spells
momentarily
I have so many questions
also my rating is higher now
okay
duck E2
I wonder so
is it worth using a jump to jump over
the duck probably not
so let's just play D4 and
duck
man so the combination of like the
freeze and using the duck could be
like very powerful
title Tuesday is over let me change the
stream title to duck spell chess
so we have Knight F6
let's just defend
and I'll have the duck return
to E6
and there's so much to comprehend here
it's nice being white though I feel like
white has a
um inherent advantage
just controlling the center
okay now I'll develop the bishop and
ducky six again so now the Knight moves
I can
jump over and take the queen unless
Knight moves and then he places a doc on
F6
and there's so many variables to keep in
mind
and neither of us have used our our
jumper free spells yet
wow
oh what a tricky move so if I wait a
minute
if I
can I jump over the no I can't jump over
the duck
what if I use my jump spell and take the
queen
no it doesn't work because there's a
duck in the way
ah and black is threatening to use the
jump spell and take my king
so can I use the freeze spell
because I play B4 and freeze
but where do I want to put the duck
yeah let's use the freeze spell
I'm gonna freeze a queen and I'm gonna
play B4
I have to move the dog pound it's only
clicking and now what do I want to block
maybe the bishop
or do I want to like guarantee myself a
move
because he's going to counter freeze my
Pawn
now let's put the duck on D7 I feel like
this this paralyzes black
pretty effectively
I'm so happy right now let's spell chess
and Duchess
it's not something I was expecting to
try today
yeah we have to do four player spell
duck shots next
uh oh
so now my Bishop's attacks my bee Pawn
is frozen my Rook is blocked by the duck
if I take then take
the duck's not really helping me
but I can play Bishop D2
and then let's put the duck here
look at this so I've prevented the queen
from retreating this way
the pawn is still attacking the queen if
the queen takes the pawn I jump my
knight and take the Queen the duck can't
interfere with that and the queen moves
this way
I'm eyeing these squares
and even if the queen moves here
if all of the queen moves here I use a
jump and take the the queen with a rook
unless a duck blocks
but the queen moves here and the duck
blocks of Bishop I still jump over the
duck
and these pawns yeah the pawns control a
lot of squares
B5 is controlled twice by nine Bishop
he plays Queen H5 and duck H3 wow
and yeah I can't
I can't use my free spell I could take
but I want to trap the queen
oh this is super clever if I play Bishop
E2 and then move the dock somewhere he
could take
by jumping over the Rook
play G4
G4 is probably no good
but I'm calculating Bishop E2
and then duck G4
Queen jumps takes H2
hmm
or takes H1
we're both getting low on time to
maybe I'll play Bishop E2 and then
doc H4
okay that way I save my Rook
and
I guess I'm allowing the queen to jump
over
but I won't mind if we trade queens and
black would waste a jump there
generally you don't want to use a jump
just to trade
and yeah after the next move our free
spells will replenish
we might see Queen G6
and black has a little bit more time
we do see Queen G6
so it's a double threat
I mean I feel like I can
that's awkward actually I play E5
perhaps
let's go for E5 and duck G5
keeping some initiative
and now the free spell is back
so it's a big question how do I use my
spells along with my duck
to oh wow
should I be afraid I think I'll take the
Knight
and then where I want to put the duck
though
duck F1
I'm just losing my Rook
I'm losing my Rook but maybe there's
some compensation
foreign
so if black takes and freezes all
counter freeze so I think I'm okay in
that regard
and now I wonder if I can play Bishop B5
sack the bishop takes and then here
is that we're sagging the bishop to get
initiative like that I think it is
and just for fun I'll put the duck on G2
no let's put the duck on F1
ensuring that if Queen takes G1 the duck
has to move then I can jump over my king
to take
I think that's very important
so this is more of a defensive idea even
though it looks like I'm blocking myself
in
ah but he prevents
he prevents me from something Queenie
too
okay I'll take and threaten
to take in the friend uh
Knight C7
I have 20 seconds left
it looks like my position's crumbling
the Vox King is definitely a Target
okay now it's a good move probably
play this and then this
might I just blunder
I think I just plunder right now
yeah that's not good
save me
I flagged
what was I gonna do though I had to I
had to freeze
was there any hope if I freeze take and
then duck
no I don't think that helps me
because he just takes
he doesn't have to freeze he just takes
and
wait can you move the duck if it's
frozen
I guess the duck is unfreezable yeah if
the duck could be Frozen that would be
weird
yeah this this was not good for me
rematch
that was very confusing
but okay
I think I think I'm ready to get revenge
all right let's play Knight C6
and duck
E2
yeah because in Duck chess you always
have to move the duck
so I guess that rule overrides the rule
of the freeze
wait a minute can I take
and
can I take and duck
here
because if
if white jumps and takes the knights
I would jump but I guess white could
take wait
could jump and then uh put the duck on
the D file and then I can't jump over
the duck and the pawn
it's so confusing
we might see this move
like jump
and then duck D6 so I can't take back
but I can freeze
and then Pawnee five but then Bishop B5
wait cancel cancel
oh but the spell hasn't replenished yet
so Bishop B5 is not a real threat
I don't think
unless it is
no I'll just use a duck to block it
okay so let's freeze a queen and play E5
and then move the dock I can move the
duck where am I going to move the duck
I'll just move the duck here
or maybe here
wait what do I want to stop
maybe here to block the bishop
then he's going to move the duck
no maybe I should go here
that way he's gonna have to move the
duck away from E7 then either I get
Bishop B5 or queen H4
I think
this is so confusing though
ah
okay so we see Bishop B5
now I'm not so scared of that because I
have
Queen H4
and then duck
C6
Actually I don't even need to play Dark
wait wait cancel
Queen H4
because white doesn't have a spell
now let's play Queen h4. C6
yeah the Spells are still
um unavailable because they're
replenishing
and not only am I threatening the queen
oh I forgot the duck could go here
uh oh
I thought I was being clever
and the jump spell is about to replenish
I have to play King d8
I'm getting crushed here
yeah after my next move lights jump
replenishes so I have to address this I
think the only move is King d8
and then
I probably have to put the duck here so
The Rook doesn't take my queen
that backfired
do I have this move
no I would take and then put the duck
here I think
duck would save me
yeah it's like the duck can block the
potential jump threats I'm pretty sure
this might be a move though
can the duck see me from that
duck here
ah what I could do if if we see this and
then duck G3 I taken duck F5
and then white would have to use another
jump spell to take the queen
we see that insteads I could take the
Rook using my jump
I think I'll take the Rook
this looks terrifying
and then put the duck on E7
so I'm basically preventing
I'm trying to prevent scary things from
happening
I'm realizing this move would threaten
to take my queen and my king
and I don't have any jump to capture
what a move but I can freeze
I can freeze a queen
I think I have to go for the freeze
or maybe maybe I move my king
move the king and put the duck here
I can't lose my queen
yeah let's move the king
oh man
I might be in big trouble here
I could also move here in Duck C6
maybe I'll do that
I'm so confused
because I taken freeze no
here and then here okay let's try this
dog is barking do you want a bacon
treats here we go
yeah this might be my final game I have
to take the dog out soon
34 seconds
so I prevented Queen takes
I'm hoping my
my jump spell will replenish in time to
threaten
to take the king
although it's terrifying
like what if I just takes and freezes me
I feel like white should be winning here
somehow
freezes my queen
uh interesting
so let's counter freeze the bishop
and play F6
and then move the duck
and next move
my my jump spell will come back so I
will be threatening to take the king
I have 12 seconds
we both use our freezes now it's just
a matter can white use a jump
effectively next turn
I have to take and then
probably this
okay so I'm preventing Bishop C4 which
was scary
let's go white blunder the queen I
forgot I could use a jump
but now I'm out of jumps
I still have a freeze left but I have an
extra Queen
should be enough and I have a duck
threatening to take
this
foreign
but I'm using the duck to defend my
queen so Rook was threatening to jump
oh yes my duck
isn't a g5's a move
but the bishop can't double jump
thank you lonely winter
if you're just joining this is spell
duck chess
we're both getting low on time I've used
my jump spells I have three freezes left
play this and this
oh I forgot about my queen though
that will be White's final jump I'll be
able to take back
or maybe take here
I probably let's take here and then trap
The Rook with the duck
no I can't Castle
uh
now it takes longer to make every move
I probably could have taken the night
there
I'm up I'm up a rook and a bishop
should be enough
we have an end game
there there
no more jump spells
three freezes each
so I'm just consolidating
it's freeze and take the night
and then move the duck
yeah the duck can't be frozen oh he can
counter freeze
okay I want on time
oh what a crazy crazy game that was fun
thank you uh thank you Brigham for the
games
um
yeah this will probably be a a YouTube
video
spell chess meets dark chess